ep
le nombre de comptes m
si on rapportait à la populaire
si on a doublé en moins de deux semaines
hier 527 de nos compatriotes sont
décédés du coït 19 hier nous avons
dénombré près de 3000 personnes en
réanimation
soit plus de la moitié des capacités
nationales à la différence de la
première vague l'ensemble des régions se
trouve aujourd'hui au seuil d alerte
dans de nombreux endroits pour prendre
en charge les patients coville 19 nous
avons commencé à des programmes et des
opérations du coeur ou du cancer parfois
les mêmes qui avait dû être décalée au
printemps nous avons pris des mesures
elle était déjà difficile et je sais
qu'elles ont été perçues comme telles
par beaucoup d'entre vous elle était
indispensable et elles ont souvent été
contestée parce qu'elle ne faisait pas
plaisir
elle se révèle toutefois insuffisantes
pour endiguer une vague qui aujourd'hui
touchent toute l'europe
notre stratégie a été définie dès l'été
c'était de vivre avec le virus
il s'agissait de maîtriser sa
circulation en nous appuyant sur nos
capacités pour tester alerte et protégé
sur les gestes barrières sur la
protection des plus fragiles et des
mesures de ralentissement de l'épidémie
territorialisée au plus près du terrain
c'est ce que nous avons fait depuis le
mois d'août avons-nous tout bien fait
non et je les dis il ya quinze jours on
peut toujours s'améliorer mais nous
avons fait tout notre possible et je
crois profondément que notre stratégie
était compte tenu des informations qui
étaient les nôtres la bonne elle fut
d'ailleurs celle de tous les pays
européens
nous aurions pu aller plus vite au début
sur les tests mais depuis plusieurs
semaines nous sommes un des pays
d'europe qui testent le plus nous
aurions collectivement sans doute dû
davantage respecté les gestes barrière
en particulier au sein de la famille ou
avec les amis qui sont les lieux où nous
sommes le plus contaminé
faut-il nous le reprocher maintenant
mais surtout il faut reconnaître que
comme tous nos voisins nous sommes
submergés par l'accélération soudaine de
l'épidémie par un virus qui semble
gagner en force à mesure que l'hiver
approche que les températures baissent
une fois encore il faut avoir beaucoup
d'humilité nous sommes tous en europe
surpris par l'évolution du virus
certains pays comme l'espagne l'irlande
les pays bas ont pris plus tôt des
mesures plus dures que les nôtres
pourtant tous nous en sommes au même
point
débordé par une deuxième vague qui nous
le savons désormais sera sans doute plus
dur et plus meurtrière que la première à
ce stade nous savons que quoi que nous
fassions près de 9000 patients seront en
réanimation à la mi-novembre soit la
quasi totalité des capacités françaises
nous nous organisons nous nous
organisons bien sûr pour y faire face
rouvrir des lits supplémentaires et nous
allons faire le maximum d'efforts tous
ensemble mais ce n'est pas suffisant si
nous ne donnons pas aujourd'hui un coup
de frein brutal aux contaminations nos
hôpitaux seront très vite saturés sans
que nous ayons cette fois la possibilité
de transférer beaucoup de patients d'une
région à une autre parce que le virus
est partout si nous ne donnons pas
aujourd'hui un coup de frein brutal aux
contaminations
les médecins devront alors choisir ici
entre un patient atteint du code vie d
une personne victime d'un accident de la
route
là entre deux malades du cog vide ce qui
compte tenu des valeurs qui sont les
nôtres de ce qu'est la france de ce que
nous sommes et inacceptable dans ce
contexte ma responsabilité est de
protéger tous les français et en dépit
des polémiques en dépit de la difficulté
des décisions à prendre
je les assume pleinement devant vous ce
soir
quelles sont nos objectifs d'abord c'est
le premier protéger les plus âgés les
plus fragiles celles et ceux qui sont
atteints de diabète d'obésité
d'hypertension de maladies chroniques et
qui sont les premières victimes
du coup vite 19 l'âge est le facteur
prépondérant 85 % des malades décédés ou
plus de 70 ans
notre deuxième objectif c'est de
protéger les plus jeunes je l' ai déjà
dit
si le virus tue les plus âgés ils tuent
aussi même si c'est rare les plus jeunes
aujourd'hui au moment où je vous parle
35% des personnes en réanimation ou
moins de 65 ans il touche donc sous des
formes graves
toutes les générations et nous ne savons
pas dire aujourd'hui quelles sont les
séquelles à long terme perte d'odorat
perte de goût difficultés respiratoires
contracté ce virus n'est jamais anodin
même lorsqu'on a 20 ans troisième
objectif c'est de protéger nos soignants
qui à l'hôpital dans les structures
médico sociales en ville ont déjà
beaucoup donné durant le printemps
ils ont ensuite dû redoubler d'activité
durant l'été pour rattraper les acteurs
reporté au printemps
et malgré la fatigue ils font face
aujourd'hui à cette montée soudaine des
urgences nous leur devons de prendre
toutes les précautions pour limiter la
propagation du virus
si nous ne le faisons pas pour nous pour
nos proches faisons le pour eux il
s'agit troisièmement de protéger les
plus modestes qui parce qu'ils vivent
dans des lieux plus exigus parce qu'ils
occupent des emplois précaires sont les
plus touchés par le virus
sur le plan sanitaire mais ce sont aussi
les plus touchés par les conséquences
économiques et sociales de la crise
enfin il nous faut protéger notre
économie
je ne crois pas à l'opposition entre
santé et économie que certains
voudraient instaurer
il n'y a pas d'économie prospère dans
une situation sanitaire dégradées avec
un virus qui circule activement et je
vous le dis très clairement il n'y a pas
non plus un système de santé qui tient
s'il n'y a pas une économie forte pour
le financer c'est donc un juste
équilibre qu'il nous faut sans cesse
rechercher sans jamais perdre de vue un
principe intangible
pour nous rien n'est plus important que
la vie humaine qu'elles sont dès lors
les stratégies possibles pour arriver à
ses objectifs nous pourrions certains
préconisent ne rien faire et assumée de
laisser le virus circule et
c'est ce qu'on appelle la recherche de
l'immunité collective c'est à dire
lorsque 50 60 % de la population a été
contaminé le conseil scientifique à
évaluer les conséquences d'une telle
option elles sont implacables à très
court terme cela signifie le tri entre
les patients à l'hôpital
et d'ici quelques mois c'est au moins
quatre cent mille morts supplémentaires
à déplorer jamais la france n'a doctorat
cette stratégie jamais nous ne
laisserons mourir des centaines de
milliers de nos concitoyens
ce ne sont pas nos valeurs ça n'est pas
non plus notre intérêt une deuxième voie
serait de confiner les seules personnes
à risque
cette voie n'est pas non plus au moment
où je vous parle utilisable d'abord elle
suppose une discussion éthiques
mais d'une part nos aînés comme les
personnes vulnérables souvent besoin
d'une assistance extérieure pour leurs
soins leur ménage la livraison de leurs
repas certains vivent aussi avec leurs
proches leurs enfants souvent par manque
de moyens et donc créer une forme de
bulle autour d'une génération de
certaines personnes comme une barrière
entre les générations n'est pas réaliste
et à ce stade insuffisant
d'autre part le virus se développe aussi
et développent des formes graves chez
les plus jeunes et donc confiné des
seules personnes âgées est inefficace
parce que le virus circule ray toujours
trop vite c'est sous des formes graves
dans le reste de la population et donc
nous ne pourrions pas protéger nos
soignants nos urgences et même à terme
nos aînés avec cette stratégie
elle peut être pertinente elle n'est pas
suffisante
nous pourrions également faire en
quelque sorte le pari de tout miser sur
la stratégie du tester alerte et
protégés après tout nous réalisons 1,9
million de tests par semaine nous sommes
l'un des meilleurs pays d'europe
aujourd'hui en la matière et grâce au
travail remarquable de l'assurance
maladie des agences régionales de santé
cent mille appels sont passées chaque
jour pour identifier les cas contacts et
briser les chaînes de contamination mais
si ce système peut être efficace avec
quelques milliers de cas par jour
nous avons aujourd'hui entre 40 et 50
mille
contamination quotidienne des pistes et
sans doute en réalité le double ce
système mais plus efficace et d'ailleurs
aucun pays européen ne le retient plus
aujourd'hui
quant à la piste de l'augmentation de
nos capacités de réanimation que
certains évoquent comme une piste qui
nous permettraient de ne pas prendre des
mesures difficiles aujourd'hui je vais
vous dire très clairement nous sommes en
train de le faire mais là non plus ça
n'est pas une bonne réponse nous avons
les stocks de médicaments les
respirateurs les masques les blues les
gants tout le matériel nécessaire parce
que nous avons appris de nos
insuffisances de nos manques
durant la première phase nous avons
aussi formé près de 7000 7000 infirmiers
et médecins pour pouvoir travailler en
réanimation et nous avons ainsi pousser
nos capacités qui sont passés de 5000
lits avant la première vague assimile
aujourd'hui et nous allons les porter au
delà de dix mille lits en réanimation
donc un effort colossal a été fait de
formation d'investissement mais il n'est
pas suffisant face à cette vague
nous agissons aussi sur le moyen terme
le ségur de la santé qui correspond à 8
milliards d'investissements par an
investi dans l'hôpital et notre santé
permettra de renforcer l'attractivité
des métiers mais il faut cinq ans pour
former un infirme et réanimateurs dix
ans pour former un anesthésiste il n'y a
pas de solution magique ça n'est pas en
quelques mois que nous pourrons créer
véritablement une capacité totalement
différente
nous ne pourrons pas non plus compte
tenu du fait que les autres pays
européens sont saturés faire appel à une
main d'oeuvre étrangère à court terme
du reste
quand bien même nous pourrions ouvrir
beaucoup plus de lits et malgré l'effort
de doublement que nous avons réussi
qui peut sérieusement vouloir que des
milliers de nos compatriotes passent des
semaines en réanimation avec les
séquelles que cela implique sur le plan
médical quel est donc aujourd'hui la
bonne stratégie à retenir confiner les
plus âgées les plus vulnérables tester
alerté protéger augmenté des lits de
réanimation
aucune de ces solutions n'est suffisante
en l'état actuel il faut aller plus loin
après avoir consulté les scientifiques
dialoguer avec les forces politiques
économiques et sociales après avoir
échangé aussi avec tous nos partenaires
européens et peser le pour et le contre
j'ai décidé qu'il fallait retrouver à
partir de vendredi
le confinement qui a stoppé le virus
tout le territoire national est concerné
avec des adaptations pour les seuls
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
mais parce que nous avons appris des
événements du printemps ce confinement
sera adapté sur trois points principaux
les écoles resteront ouvertes le travail
pourra continuer les ehpad et les
maisons de retraite pourront être
visités quelles seront les règles de
cette nouvelle étape et le gouvernement
demain les détaillera lors d'une
conférence de presse il ya d'abord ce
qui ne changera pas par rapport à ce que
nous avons vécu au printemps comme au
printemps vous pourrez sortir de chez
vous uniquement pour travailler vous
rendre à un rendez vous médical pour
porter assistance à un proche pour faire
vos courses essentielles ou prendre
l'air à proximité de votre domicile
c'est donc le retour de l'attestation
comme au printemps les réunions privées
en dehors du strict noyau familial
seront donc exclus les rassemblements
publics seront interdits et vous ne
pourrez pas vous déplacer d'une région à
l'autre à l'exception des retours de
vacances de la toussaint et donc il y
aura une tolérance
durant ce week-end de retour pour que
chacune et chacun puisse revenir de son
lieu de vacances pour que les familles
puissent organiser les commerces qui ont
été définies au printemps comme non
essentiels les établissements recevant
du public
notamment les bars et restaurants seront
fermées comme au printemps le quoi qu'il
en coûte cette réponse économique
parmi les plus protectrices du monde se
poursuivra elle sera même plus important
ce qu'en plus importante qu'en mars pour
une petite entreprise fermée
administrativement avec la prise en
charge jusqu'à 10000 euros par mois de
leurs pertes en chiffre d'affaires les
salariés et les employeurs qui ne
peuvent pas travailler continueront
quant à eux à bénéficier du chômage
partiel et nous compléterons par des
mesures de trésorerie pour les charges
les loyers des prochaines semaines et un
plan spécial sera fait pour les
indépendants les commerçants les très
petites et moyennes entreprises qui je
le sais redoutent plus que tout les
prochaines semaines par rapport à mars
avril
nous avons je le disais à prix nous
avons progressé c'est pourquoi certaines
règles vont évoluer
d'abord nos enfants ne saurait être
durablement privé d'instruction
d'éducation de contact avec le système
scolaire trop de conséquences trop de
dégâts en particulier pour les plus
modestes
les crèches les écoles les collèges et
les lycées demeureront donc ouvert avec
des protocoles sanitaires renforcés les
facultés et établissement d'enseignement
supérieur assureront al'inverse des
cours en ligne partout c'est possible
télétravail sera à nouveau
généraliser mais et c'est une seconde
différence par rapport au printemps
l'activité continuera avec plus
d'intensité
ce qui veut dire que les guichets des
services publics resteront ouverts les
usines les exploitations agricoles les
bâtiments et travaux publics
continueront de fonctionner l'économie
ne doit ni s'arrêter ni s'effondrait je
vous invite donc dans la mesure des
possibilités de chacun à participer de
cet effort en travaillant en soutenant
les entreprises aussi qui proche de chez
vous ont innové à travers des commandes
à distance la vente à emporter ou la
livraison à domicile
le gouvernement d'ailleurs accompagnera
les très petites et
petites entreprises comme les moyennes
entreprises les artisans aussi qu'ils
entreprendront des démarches de
numérisation nos frontières intérieures
à l'espace européen demeureront ouvertes
et sauf exception les frontières
extérieures resteront fermés bien
évidemment les français de l'étranger
resteront libres de regagner le
territoire dans les ports les aéroports
pour les déplacements internationaux des
tests rapides obligatoires seront
déployés pour toutes les arrivées aucun
voyageur ne doit pouvoir entrer sur le
territoire européen sans qu'on soit
certain qu'il n'est pas porteur du virus
enfin pour éviter que ne se nouent des
drames humains que nous avons vécue au
printemps ou des personnes en fin de vie
se retrouve totalement isolé les visites
en maison de retraite et en ehpad seront
cette fois autorisée dans le strict
respect des règles sanitaires
je souhaite aussi que les personnes en
situation de handicap puissent
bénéficier des souplesses dont elles ont
besoin
quant au cimetière en cette période
marquée par la toussaint ils demeureront
ouverts et je veux que nous puissions
continuer à enterrer dignement nos
proches
ce nouveau confinement ne réussira que
par la mobilisation de tous et chacun a
son rôle à jouer aux personnes à risque
aux plus vulnérables aux personnes âgées
de plus de 70 ans je demande une
vigilance accrue moins de réunions avec
la famille avec les amis même si c'est
un crève coeur et le respect de la
distanciation physique y compris au
domicile le port du masque systématique
lorsqu'on se trouve à l'intérieur en
présence d'une autre personne même un
proche même un enfant ou un petit enfant
c'est très important pour vous
les soignants à l'hôpital joue
évidemment dans ce contexte un rôle
essentiel mais nous avons besoin des
médecins de ville
des infirmiers des pharmaciens de tous
les acteurs du médico social de tous les
professionnels de santé de ville pour
assurer une prise en charge précoce des
patients dès les premiers symptômes
et pour éviter que ne se développent des
formes complexes nous avons besoin de
nos élus nos mères ont joué un rôle
essentiel et je les salue ici
mr présidents présidents
d'intercommunalités de métropole élus de
terrain nous allons avoir besoin de vous
de manière encore accrue pour proposer
et aller plus loin en matière de
prévention mobiliser nos associations
pour accompagner les personnes les plus
isolées les moins bien informés et
assuré la bonne application des mesures
prises que ce soit auprès de nos jeunes
dans le temps périscolaire ou pour
accompagner les personnes les plus
vulnérables ou les plus âgés nous avons
besoin de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure pour garantir l'application
des mesures de nos forces de sécurité
civile pour déployer des plateformes de
test est allé au contact de la
population
nous avons aussi besoin du sens des
responsabilités de chacun et de l'esprit
citoyen de tous rester au maximum chez
vous respectez les règles
une fois encore je vous le dis la
réussite dépend du civisme de chacune et
chacun d'entre nous comment cette
nouvelle étape va se dérouler dans le
temps chaque heure compte l'ensemble de
ces mesures doivent donc entrer en
application au plus vite
elles le seront dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi et elles seront appliquées à
minima jusqu'au 1er décembre dès demain
un débat suivi d'un vote se tiendra au
parlement dès demain le gouvernement
détaillera toutes ces mesures nous
devons nous honorer de cette
transparence et du fait que des
décisions difficiles se fasse dans un
cadre démocratique où toutes les
oppositions peuvent s'exprimer dès
demain également je participerai un
conseil européen pour coordonner les
réponses sanitaires des différents pays
de l'union
tous les quinze jours nous ferons le
point sur l'évolution de l'épidémie nous
déciderons le cas échéant de mesures
complémentaires et nous évaluerons alors
si nous pouvons aller j'ai certaines
contraintes en particulier sur les
commerces
je sais que beaucoup de commerçants
espérer ne pas fermer
je sais que pour les commerces de centre
ville je demande un très gros effort
tenons le avec beaucoup de rigueur
pendant quinze jours
si d'ici 15 jours nous maîtrisons mieux
la situation nous pourrons alors évalué
les choses est espéré ouvrir certains
commerces en particulier dans cette
période si importante avant les fêtes de
noël
nous verrons si nous pouvons cultiver
l'espoir de célébrer en famille ce
moment si précieux de noël et des fêtes
de fin d'année notre objectif à terme
est simple réduire très fortement les
contaminations est passé de 40 mille
contamination par jour à 5000 ralentir
significativement le rythme des entrées
à l'hôpital est en réanimation et ce
n'est qu'alors que nous pourrons
pleinement redéployer une stratégie
tester alerté protéger renouveler
complété c'est pourquoi durant ces
semaines nous allons aussi produire des
efforts massifs pour mettre en place
beaucoup plus de plateformes de test à
travers des innovations une nouvelle
organisation nous devons collectivement
déployer beaucoup plus massivement
l'application tout senti qu vide qui
sera un instrument de la sortie de cette
phase de confinement test en 30 minutes
meyer traçage isolement plus efficace
des personnes positives qui est un sujet
sur lequel nous devons continuer à
réfléchir une fois le pic épidémique
passé
tous ces outils doivent nous permettre
demain de tenir jusqu'aux vaccin à l'été
nous disent les scientifiques
mes chers compatriotes nous avons tous
été surpris par l'accélération soudaine
de l'épidémie tous si je sais la
lassitude et cette impression d'un jour
sans fin qui tous nous gagne nous devons
quoi qu'il arrive rester unis et
solidaires et ne pas céder au poison de
la division
cette période est difficile parce
qu'elle éprouve justement notre
résilience et notre unité
mais elle est un révélateur de ce que
nous sommes des femmes et des hommes qui
sont liés les uns aux autres très peu de
générations auront eu comme la nôtre
autant de défis ensemble cette pandémie
historique les crises internationales le
terrorisme les divisions de la société
et une crise économique et sociale sans
précédent liée à la première vague mais
j'ai confiance en nous en vous confiance
en notre capacité à surmonter cette
épreuve
nous devons tenir chacun à notre place
dans la transparence le débat dans la
détermination pour appliquer les règles
que nous nous fixons et en nous serrant
les coudes à nouveau nous nous
relèverons
si nous sommes unis et nous serons unis
nous avons besoin les uns des autres
nous sommes une nation unie et solidaire
et c'est à cette condition que nous y
arriverons nous sommes la france
je compte sur chacun d'entre vous je
serai là nous serons là et nous y
arriverons
tous ensemble vive la république et vive
la france